агресором школи будуть відновлювати за
новими технологіями безпеки у
Міністерстві освіти і науки презентували
програму освіта чотирикрапка нуль
української Світанок вона стосується
всіх ланок освіти і частиною плану
відновлення України після перемоги
стратегічна мета євроінтеграція освіти
починаючи від сучасної інфраструктури
закінчуючи
dg-джиталізацією процесу навчання
зокрема у мон у партнерстві з мінцефра
анонсували запуску освітнього паспорту
смартфонів
докладніше про це поговоримо
з міністром освіти Сергієм шкарлутом він
зараз доєднується до нашого ефіру п
міністр Я вас вітаю в нашому ефірі Слава
Україні
Героям слава Вітаю вас пане міністр
спочатку повномасштабного вторгнення
майже три тисячі навчальних закладів
постраждали від російських атак Та от
Попри
це перший семестр воєнного навчального
року от майже все-таки закінчується і
попереду Як ми знаємо довгі зимові
канікули чи всюди от вони триватимуть
довше звичайно розкажіть нам будь ласка
перш за все дуже дякую за запитання Дуже
дякую вам за увагу до освіти адже ми
завжди кажемо що освіта - це про
майбутнє складне запитання але дуже дуже
такий інформативно оскільки дійсно
приблизно 2800 українських шкіл
розпочали навчальний рік в стані або
зруйнування або пошкодження І звісно що
діти
в сьогодні в залежності від ситуації від
локації від місцезнаходження від
погодних умов знаходяться не в рівних
умовах і саме канікули в абсолютно вірно
зазначили можуть тривати трошки довше
ніж зазвичай але це сьогодні
встановлюється саме педрада між шкіл і
затверджується засновниками Ми сьогодні
звісно враховуємо і погоду і
опалювальний сезон і
безпечне знаходження в частині ну в
частині
навіть збереження здоров'я безпечне
знаходження в закладах освіти навіть ті
заклади які
не зможуть усувати
[музика]
в онлайн або в змішаному в нас
12911 шкіл сьогодні працює по Україні це
досить високий результат і вчителі
проявляють абсолютно іншу
педмайстерність ніж навіть до війни до
ковіду дозволяють зробити все щоб втрата
якості освіти була мінімальною Дуже
дякуємо А скажіть нам будь ласка от ті
школи які все-таки будуть змушені піти
на оці довгострокові канікули вони
будуть тривати місяць як будуть
працювати в цей період вчителі і чи
будуть в цих школах продовжений от
обпалювальний е-е оцей от сезон чи буде
опалюватися школи
ви знаєте на якщо пішли діти на канікули
того сенсу опалювати школи як на мій на
мій розум сьогодні не потрібно але при
цьому вирішуються засновники вирішують
самі школи стосовно стосовно опалення
стосовно виплати своїх комунальних
платежів в залежності від місцевих
бюджетів на яких вони знаходяться
вчителі в будь-якому випадку працюють
вчителі в цей час будуть займатися з
цими дітьми які
трошки не засвоїли матеріал це є
можливість повторити матеріал дати більш
глубокий додаткові роз'яснення вчителі
всі працюють консультують проводять
виховну психологічну підтримку учням і
батькам в тому числі
пане міністр я пам'ятаю як от Влітку ми
слідкували за тим як готуються школи до
навчального сезону тоді ви нам кожного
тижня в ефірі казали що от уже 30% шкіл
підготувалися підготовлені бомбосховища
а потім 45% 50 Якщо я не помиляюся
почали ми навчальний рік школи були
готові на 60%, яка от ситуація за оці на
півроку чи підготовлені ще більшою шкіл
Чи йде модернізація А от як розвиваються
події Дуже дякую Дуже слушне запитання
ви знаєте ми з вами десь закінчили такий
марафон щодо укриттів безпечного
середовища по школах фізично
інфраструктурного безпечного
середовищах в цілому позакладах освіти
приблизно на цифрі
59,9% всіх закладів освіти по Україні на
сьогодні майже
68% всіх закладів всіх типів закладів
України обладнані укриттями і мають
статус безпечного освітнього середовища
тобто школа або закладу освіти - це
територія безпеки ми поступово активно
впроваджуємо життя Що стосується
закладів загальної середньої освіти то
на сьогодні ми закінчили марафон такий
активний звітувати стосовно укриттів це
було приблизно в
63,64%. на сьогодні я вам хочу
прозвітувати
74,7% закладів загальної середньої
освіти тобто шкіл обладнані укриття
укриттям і можуть і мають навчати дітей
очно це над великі показник ми тоді
говорили що ми якщо ми стартували з 11%
на початку липня то На сьогодні це 74,7
якщо Брати по інших закладах освіти
наприклад фахова передвичка тобто
коледжі це в нас 87.8 а-а профтех - це
майже 95% оскільки вони більш за всіх
потребують наявність укриття і очного
навчання оскільки там професійні навички
дошкільна освіта це 56,1 дитячий садочки
а інші заклади освіти тобто позашкільна
приблизно
64%. хочу вам приклад Київську область
де навіть після повномасштабного
російської агресії після руйнування
величезної кількості закладів в нас уже
9 загальної середньої освіти відновлено
і 45 дитячих садочків
від запущено в роботу Це є приклад Нам
усім як треба працювати на користь того
щоб освіта розвивалася в ім'я наших
дітей
пан міністр А чи є от змога адаптувати
освітні процеси от під ці важкі реалії
відсутності світла які от ми зараз всі
переживаємо
ви знаєте декілька разів вже відповідав
на це запитання з задоволенням повторюсь
що міністерством освіти і науки разом з
директорами департаментів обласних
департаментів освіти і науки обласних
військових адміністрацій напрацьовано
величезну кількість практичних
рекомендацій які взяті саме з досвіду
передового досвіду з так званих
лайфхаків саме наших вчителів Ми
сьогодні забезпечуємо освітній процес
незалежно від наявності або відсутності
світла від наявності або відсутності
тепла від наявності або відсутності
сховища від того чи це територія
окупована або деокукована освітній
процес охоплений
всіма доступними способами і наше
завдання Сьогодні жодної дитини немає
бути поза освітні процеси і ми поступово
до цього рухаємося знаєте в цьому
контексті навіть при відсутності світла
ми застосовуємо модель асиміляції
синхронного і асинхронного навчання ми
застосовуємо можливість без інтернетних
застосунків для гаджетів цей для
планшетів і для
мобільних телефонів для того щоб ми
певним чином могли навіть при
відсутності інтернета при заряджених або
за допомогою повербанка користуватися
своїми гаджетами ми переводимо
всеукраїнську школу нашу національну
платформу Всеукраїнських школах онлайн в
режим асинхронного сприйняття
викладачі застосовують цілу низку мету
щодо повторення матеріалу індивідуальних
або міні-групових занять з нашими
студентами до цього долучаємося не
студентами а учнями до цього долуча
батьків до цього долучаємо аспірантів до
цього долучаємо взагалі всіх всі можливі
засоби для того щоб діти не залишились
позаосвітнім процесом і підтвердження
м першого семестру 22-го року коли жодна
дитина не була не табельована всі
дев'ятикласники отримали свідоцтво про
базову загальну середню освіту А всі
11-класники отримали диплом про
закінчення повної загальної середньої
освіти
пане міністр от перед нашою з вами
бесідою я трохи розповів от про велику
трансформацію освіти розкажіть нам будь
ласка детальніше от що вона передбачає
Ну по-перше вона починалася після того
як президент України Володимир
Олександрович Зеленський оголосив план
великої трансформації взагалі України
план відновлення України і кожному з
членів уряду було поставлено завдання в
межах компетенції допрацювати програму
кожного Міністерства по своїй галузі
щодо на підставі плану відновлення щодо
тих кроків освіти які має зробити саме
Міністерство освіти і науки саме заклади
освіти підвідомчі установи і команда
Хочу зазначити що над планом над великим
планом який презентував саме
всесвітньо-економічного форумі працювало
більше ніж 130 експертів які працювали в
галузі освіти і науки очолював Сергій
Бабак приймав активну участь заступник у
голови офісу президента Олексій дніпров
ціла низка була експертів громадських
народних депутатів і на підставі плану
відновлення презентованого на
всесвітньо-економічному форумі
Міністерство розробляло свою програму
великої трансформації освіта 4:0
українські свята на підставі ми
формування цієї програми в тому що ми
маємо рухатись якщо ми рухаємось
Європейський простір то так само ми
маємо по освіті рухатись в європейській
освітній простір а це означає що ми
маємо чітко
трансформувати нашу освіту освіту 2:0
сьогодні в освіту 4:0 оскільки весь Світ
рухається до індустрії 4:0 і саме
відповідність індустріального
індустріальної революції
теорії індустрії 4:0 саме мають
відповідати освітні навички Сьогодні ми
в цьому контексті розробили і створили
певний певне взаємодію між
контентом і досвідом в рамках кожної з
освітніх грузей тобто від дошкільної
шкільної позашкільної загальної
середньої
професійно-технічної освіти фахової
перевищення освіти вищої освіти і так
званої освіти впродовж життя Ми заклали
один з принципів який ми будемо сьогодні
модерувати в якості експеримента гроші
ходять за за клієнтом ми заклали су
б'єкт особи яка навчається якщо до цього
особа яка навчається була лише об'єктом
освіти то в цьому контексті ми заклали
її суб'єктність ми заклали
взаємозгоджені принципи е-е всіх е-е
стейкхолдерів в частині освіти цей
Міністерство це і здобувач освіти цей
молодий науковець це і людина старшого
віку яка навчається цей держава і
підприємці організації які мають мають
споживати результати роботи освітнього
закладу А в чому полягає На жаль ми дуже
обмежені в часі дуже вам дякую за ваші
відповіді ще є дуже багато темних які
хотілося б з вами поговорити Тому дуже
будемо раді бачити вас в нашому ефірі
Наступного разу гарного вам дня привіз
надати інформацію дякую дякую вам це був
Сергій шкарлет Міністр освіти і науки
України